Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan.
And today, we are back for another episode
of Rawkode live where we take a look
at technology and the cloud native in Kubernetes
space joined by their creators for the creators,
founders, maintainers
to give us that inside look to what
the project does, the problem it solves, and
how cool it is.
Today, we're taking a look at a project
called Sveltos,
and I am joined by Jan Luka. Hello,
Adam. Welcome.
Hello, and thanks for having me here. I'm
Jan Luka. I'm a principal
engineer at Cisco. I mostly work on distributed
systems.
And on the side, like, I'm working, like,
for
many months now, over a year, like, on
projects Sveltos, which is what we cover today.
Thank you.
Awesome. Well, I'm looking forward to learning more
all about it. So you said you're a
principal engineer at Cisco. Have you been working
with Kubernetes for for long now?
Yes. I
worked at I started working Kubernetes when I
joined together. I was there for over a
year on the enterprise version of project Calico.
Ah. And then
I went
I was at Cisco, went to together, and
then went back to Cisco because they start,
like, an Kubernetes project at Cisco, and I
want to work on it. And,
yes, so now I'm back there.
Yeah. Very cool.
Well, maybe you could kinda give us the
the TLDR.
What what is Project Sveltos?
It's a project to
dynamically manage
add ons on a fleet of Kubernetes clusters.
And the
final goal will be that it's a pure
intent base. So you can express easily what
you want, what type of allowance you want,
given, like, the
state of a cluster and a bunch of
other information and Sveltos
make it happen for you.
Okay. So I have a Kubernetes cluster.
I wanna stick something onto it. I have
more than one Kubernetes cluster
as Sveltos can handle that for us.
I mean, I'm assuming when you said fleet,
right, that word to me says scale. I
have dozens, hundreds, potentially thousands of clusters. But
does it scale down well for people that
want to experiment and play with it and
just run against one or or two clusters?
It should scale pretty well. Honestly, I haven't
tested, like, with thousands clusters. This will be,
like I don't know, like, too many clusters,
but
it's the design.
It's it's it's done in a way that
it should scale.
Now what the point where it's you know,
will start having problem scaling, I honestly haven't
hit that yet. But, yes, the idea is
that you have this management cluster.
And in this management cluster, you have, Sveltos
running.
And then you have a fleet of Kubernetes
clusters,
which are your managed clusters.
The only requirement for Sveltos is that there
is network connectivity to those managed clusters.
And and from around, pretty much, you can
say, like, this is those are the ones
that I want to deploy in those clusters,
and Sveltos can can do it for you.
It's a it's it has support for cluster
API.
Initially, pretty much, like, I was the project
we were working at Cisco,
it was using cluster API to create Kubernetes
clusters on on demand, on prem.
And and that's pretty much when I realized
that there was a need. At least I
felt a need to have management
for a fleet of clusters.
And I know that there are other solutions
there, but I
think, like, Sveltos is a little bit different
because, like, it's it's goal is to be,
like, pure intent based and very dynamic in
in what it does.
You know, it deploys, like, the phones and
everything.
Nice.
Yeah. I think this is a
common scenario in Kubernetes
land. You know, we have a lot of
choice. Right? There's there's individual problems, but there
are lots of tools that come at it
from a different way. And I think, you
know, there's no one right or wrong answer.
There's the one that applies for your use
case. And, like, the more choice we have
to make there, I think it's it's always
a good thing, you know, being able to
have a like minded solution to other people
and contribute and especially in open source. Right?
Like, it's just a great possession for us
all to be in.
Absolutely. Yeah. I mean, the cases are every
I feel that too much like it's everyone
has a slightly different use case. And so
there are, like, it's the more product that
are out there, the better it is because
there is definitely, like, it's gonna be one
which is closer to solve, everybody use case.
So it's good. Yeah.
Thanks.
So I believe you have some slides you
want to run through to give us a
bit more context and information.
Yes. Left some slides just to give, like,
a
context of
how Sveltos runs, and then we can go,
like, into a demo of of the light
demo.
We like demos. Yeah.
Perfect. Yeah.
Okay. So I'll share
some slides, and I go, like, in presentation
mode.
So
we know that once we create a Kubernetes
cluster, now that is just the beginning because
after that, we have at the end to
deploy
a bunch of add ons to have, like,
a production cluster or a cluster that fulfills,
like, our needs.
So what Sveltos does, the idea of Sveltos,
is that there is one management cluster. And
in this management cluster, Sveltos is running, and
there are a bunch of
managed clusters.
Some of the cluster can be cluster API,
power clusters. Sveltos, like, fully understand
cluster API concept.
And but any other cluster pretty much can
be managed by Sveltos. As long as there
is network
connectivity and Sveltos has a cube conflict to
us is like the managed cluster, that's all
it needs.
The main CRB that Sveltos uses, it's it's
called cluster profile, and it has, like, essentially
four fields.
The first field, which is the most important,
is the not the most important, which is
like it's the the first field is the
cluster selector. The cluster selector is just like
a Kubernetes label selector.
So we have
a fleet of clusters.
Each cluster says
set of labels. These cluster selectors, in this
case, is selecting all the clusters which
match this
label selector here. So any cluster which has
a label EMV
equals to a fig, which stands like for
functional verification.
Now those clusters, what Sveltos does, it gets
all those clusters here, and then it deploys
all the ones that are listed here. And
we have three different sections. There is an
L chart sections where there can be one
or more L charts. In this case, what
I'm asking,
like, Sveltos is to deploy Caverno version 2.6
in any cluster which is missing this cluster
selector.
There is another section which is
a customization section. Essentially, here, you can defer,
like, to one or more
directories
that contain
customization file,
and Sveltos uses, like, the customized pretty much
to take the YAML and deploy the YAML
in all the managed clusters.
And finally, there is another section which is
policy ref, which essentially is referencing
secrets and config map. And each one of
the secrets config map can contain one or
more Kubernetes resources that Sveltos is gonna deploy
in all the clusters that matches the clutch
the the cluster selector.
So here I have one example of a
config map that, contain in its data section
two,
Kubernetes resources, a gateway class and a gateway.
So, what Sveltos will do if a cluster
profile is referenced in this config map, it
will deploy this gateway class and the gateway
instance in any cluster that is matching the
cluster profile that is referencing this config map.
So this is pretty much the basic idea,
to have a single
one or more cluster profile where you dictate
what add ons needs to be deployed.
And this is just like a
slide that shows, like, how Sveltos we work.
So if I post a cluster profile in
the management cluster,
and this cluster profile is a cluster selector.
In this case, it just has, like, one
single chart.
And I do have, like, two managed clusters.
As soon as I add the label environment
production to this cluster, Sveltos will detect that
this cluster is not a match for this
cluster profile.
It will take all the add ons that
are listed in this cluster profile and deploy
those.
So
will be deployed in this cluster.
And
likewise, if I add the same environment production
label on the second managed cluster,
twice exactly the same. Sveltos will detect that
this cluster is not matched for this cluster
profile. It will take all the that are
listed in the cluster profile and will deploy
those.
So Sveltos can take care of deploying,
upgrading,
but it can also take care of removing
add ons. Because, for instance, if I remove
the
label environment production for this workload cluster,
this cluster is now not matching the cluster
profile anymore.
And so Sveltos, by default, is gonna remove
all the add ons that it has installed
because of this cluster here.
This is the default behavior. It's it is
configurable what Sveltos should do
when a cluster stop matching a cluster profile.
But the default behavior, it will withdraw all
the add ons that as Sveltos is deployed.
Now I follow you, like, on Twitter,
and
I think it was a week back.
There was a thread that you posted, and
I like the statement that you put it
there. That everything that your application needs, beyond
its own declarations should come from the environment
in cluster.
And
I liked it because this is actually what
is behind Sveltos' idea.
Because, for instance,
if I have to deploy Calico in all
the clusters which are matching
the
label, the cluster selector environment production. Now Calico
requires to be passed the port CIDR
to be deployed.
Now
I know that if the cluster it's a
cluster API type of cluster, there is a
cluster instance which represents the cluster in the
management cluster.
And that cluster instance has exactly this information
that Kalliko needs.
So what I'm telling here, Sveltos, is
anytime you find a cluster which is matching
this cluster selector here,
before you deploy Calico,
take the cluster instance in the management cluster,
which represents the cluster where you are about
to deploy Calico.
Take these hider blocks
from the,
cluster instance, which sits in the management cluster,
replace it here, instantiate
this value section, and now you can go
ahead and deploy Calico.
So
it is important that
sometimes the information that
you need when you are deploying add ons
in bunch of clusters
might be present in the management cluster, and
you might wanna fetch it at run time
and then pass it along to all the
managed clusters.
Another example, like, by default, like, Sveltos,
it's
fetches like, you can fetch, like, those
resources here from the
management cluster. But Sveltos is not limited to
that. Essentially, you can tell Sveltos to fetch
anything and use it. In this case, I'm
telling Sveltos to fetch a resource, a secret,
which is present in management cluster, which is
called which is in the default namespace. It's
called autoscaler. And I want Sveltos to represent
this resource with the autoscaler secret ID. And
so now this config map here
can actually use any
information which is present in this in this
secret. If you see, it's like Sveltos fetches
the secret, default autoscaler,
it
names it autoscaler secret. And now if I
look at the config map, the config map,
it's actually pretty much using the autoscaler secret
and seems like, I wanna take the namespace
of the secret, and I wanna take the
data token of the secrets, and I wanna
take the data section
CA CRT of the secret. In this case,
pretty much the secrets contains
a certificate and a token, and I wanna
pass it, like, to the managed cluster because
I wanna create a sequence in the managed
cluster which contains this information. So it's very
dynamic
because that too much, like, it's it's it's
the main goal one of the main goal
of Sveltos.
The other features that I'm gonna demo,
it's
it's what I'm gonna cover, like, here in
the next two slides. Essentially, so far, what
we have said is that the
platform admin in the management cluster is the
one that is in charge of adding labels
to the managed clusters.
But, ideally, I don't wanna do that. For
instance, if I have two different admins, right,
I might have one admin which is in
charge of deciding which is the Kubernetes version
in each of the managed clusters.
And I might have a different admin which
might be in charge of deciding which add
ons needs to be deployed.
Now I wanna I don't want to require
those two admins to talk to each other.
So if I need to upgrade the cluster,
I don't have to go to the add
on admin and say,
is there any action that you have to
take care before I upgrade the cluster or
after I upgrade the
cluster? I want that to be, like,
taken care of by Sveltos. And so there
is a second concept that Sveltos has, which
is called classifier. Essentially, classifier is capable of
classifying a cluster based on its run time
state.
What I'm doing, like, in this example here,
I have a classifier which is saying, if
you find any cluster which is running a
Kubernetes version, is
greater than or equal to one twenty four,
but strictly less than one twenty five,
does this cluster here is a match for
this classifier, and I want you to add
automatically this label to the cluster gatekeeper v
three nine. Now if I can if I
pair this classifier with a cluster profile, which
is saying take any cluster which has this
label here gatekeeper with nine, and deploy those
add ons.
Now there is nothing else I have to
do because what happens is that as soon
as I post those two objects to the
management cluster,
Sveltos is gonna deploy an agent in each
of the managed cluster.
These agents here is gonna detect that those
two clusters are both match
and match for this classifier.
Because they are a match for this classifier,
Sveltos is gonna add the labels that he
has been instructed to add 20 cluster that
match this classifier. So now those labels, gatekeeper
59, are gonna be added to both clusters.
Because those clusters have this label here, now
they are a match for this cluster profile.
And because they are a match for this
cluster profile, gatekeeper gets deployed in all those
in both clusters automatically.
Now let's say that I am the
I
don't admin. And what I know is that
I'm fine with gate gate
gatekeeper 390
if the cluster is less than one twenty
five. But if the cluster, it's, upgraded to
one twenty five or higher, I want, gatekeeper
b three ten. So I can express my
intent simply creating another pair of classifier classifier.
I'm creating classifier that says, like, if there
is any cluster which is matching
which is
running a Kubernetes
version better or equal than one twenty five,
now I want the label gatekeeper b three
ten added to the cluster.
And then I say that, if there is
any cluster with gatekeeper v three ten, I
want gatekeeper
n chart three ten zero to be deployed.
So now let's look at this cluster here.
It's running 124.
I post select this pair of classifier and
cluster profile to the management cluster.
I upgrade the cluster to
125.
So now because the cluster has been upgraded
to 1252,
this cluster stop being a match for the
previous classifier
and becomes a match for the new classifier.
And because it becomes a match for the
new classifier,
the gatekeeper
the the label is gonna be updated
because the label is supposed to be gatekeeper
v 310. So Sveltos update update the labels
on this cluster only. The other cluster is
still matching your classifier.
Because the label on this cluster has been
updated,
this cluster becomes a match for this cluster
profile and automatically gatekeeper and chart gets upgraded
to three times zero by Sveltos.
So those are the two main features that
I'm
gonna demo today. Sveltos is like more of
those features here and did the final goal
of Sveltos, it's intent based. So it has
an event driven mechanism where it can detects
events and deploy a don't see response of
events as well.
Me
exit the
so I'm done with the slide.
Don't know if there are questions or if
you wanna make me to jump on the
demo. I can go, like, on the demo
twice.
Yeah.
Like, this really resonates
with me about the way I want my
GitOps pipelines to work. I love that you
can pull out arbitrary resources within the target
cluster and use them as part of the
templating across
the application delivery.
Like, we've had, you know, we're all we're
typically, we're all developers. Right? We've been writing
code for, say, five years, ten years, twenty
years, however long you've been writing code. We
learn all these best practices.
And I felt that every time we were
adopted get ups, we were thrown all of
that away. Like, you know, the fact that
we have CICD pipelines with baked in hard
coded environments like dev and staging and prod
infuriates
me and they're doing it because they need
to inject ingress host names and all this
other fluff.
But the cluster can provide that and like
I'm sitting here but where has Sveltos been
my entire life? Like I need this tool
and magically
your demo on it today. So I'm really
excited. I think this is a really great
addition and the way the
the classifiers are working as well on top
of that as a kind of you know,
that ad hoc
way like as my cluster evolves like we're
always oh, no. Alright.
Most people that I have spoken to are
using managed Kubernetes clusters. Right? They're not using
infrastructure as code as strictly as we used
to kind of encourage ten years ago. Right?
Because JKE, EKS, AKS, they will manage the
upgrade for us. Like, we don't even store
the versions on our IAC anymore.
And as these things are changing dynamically behind
the scenes, our IAC doesn't really know how
to react to that or do anything with
that. And there are get ups pipelines don't
have any awareness of that either.
And this kind of bridges that gap as
well.
Guess the question I have Yeah. Right? Because
I'm excited though and I'm like, I wanna
use this, but I don't have a fleet
of clusters.
Can I run Sveltos and the cluster that
it manages?
So
it's
for few things, it's the the real answer,
it's I will say it's no because it's
limited in what you can do, like, in
the cluster itself.
But
it's actually a good point. Like, I've been
thinking about, like, whether, like, you should be
able to manage even the cluster where it's
running because, ideally, it's feasible. I mean, it's
all there. It's just a matter, like,
of running the agent in the management cluster
itself,
but I've not gone there yet.
So
Yeah. Think that might be something to happen
to tie on and experiment with because, yeah,
it could be cool.
Anyway, yeah, no questions right now. Just excitement
from my end. So happy to to see
the demo and see what we're playing with
here. Thank you. Thanks.
So what what I have here, it's I
have, like, I'm I'm running in the management
clusters.
And the only thing saved so far in
the management cluster, it's
cluster API.
So and I'm using Docker as infrastructure provider.
And I did create
one cluster API cluster,
which is called
cluster API workload.
But I haven't installed Sveltos yet. I will
follow pretty much the
Sveltos.
We'll go to the document and we'll follow
the document like to install Sveltos. And I
do also have, like, two
GK clusters,
which I did create,
which I'm gonna import
and let Sveltos also manage
GK clusters. So pretty much, like, I can
show that both cluster API, power clusters, or
any other type of cluster. In this case,
GK can be managed by
by Sveltos.
So
if
if I go to
this Sveltos installation,
it's simply
as deploying those to YAML. It has, like,
an end chart as well to deploy Sveltos,
but I'm gonna, like, follow, those to simply
pretty much, like,
deploy these
these YAML to the management cluster. So I'm
gonna apply the first YAML. The first YAML
pretty much contains
all the resources and everything that Sveltos needs.
I do not have permissions installed, that's why
pretty much, like, there is this error here
because that was pretty much like if
it has Could we be seeing some light
settings? I guess those are your slides.
Oh, you're still seeing this slide. Oh, I'm
sorry.
I think yeah. So, like, let me just
I think I was sharing the okay. Sorry.
That's okay.
So I'll go here. Okay. So pretty much
what let me see. Actually, I'll I'll share
the
the entire moment. That's why I don't like
to keep switching every time. I'll share the
entire screen. And
it doesn't allow me to share the entire
screen. So okay. So pretty much, I'll like
I'll have to share and stop and share
again. So what I did, I went to
the project Sveltos
documentation,
and
this is pretty much like the install section.
And this is how pretty much I can
install Sveltos in the management cluster. So it's
just posting those to YAML.
And
what I did
I'll share my monitor now.
You know? And
want I like to share anymore. So what
I did, like, this is my management cluster,
and I would say that what I have
in the management cluster,
I did now right now, like, installs Sveltos
as well. So you just like these Sveltos
components are running in the project Sveltos namespace.
And
I do have the,
cluster API, which are installed as well. And
the, Docker is the infrastructure provider.
And I do have a cluster which is
being provided using
just
move this a little bit higher so it
doesn't bother me.
And I do have one cluster which it's
been
created using cluster API and Docker's infrastructure provider.
And I did install pretty much like Sveltos,
and now I'm installing the default classifier, which
is just need to, like, to
make sure that the agent gets deployed in
all the managed clusters.
Now
what I do have here is that I
do have also two
two GKE clusters, and I do have the
cube config of those GKE clusters.
And
what I'm going to do,
I'm going to
register those two GKE clusters with
with Sveltos as well. So Sveltos can also
manage those GKE clusters as well. So I'll
go back to the management cluster,
and I'm
going to create a namespace, which I call
GKE.
And then
Sveltos comes with the CLI.
It's not required to use the CLI, but
it's very handy when you have to do,
like,
when you wanna see what the ones have
been deployed or when you want to register
a cluster with Sveltos.
So even to register a cluster with Sveltos,
the documentation is on the
project Sveltos. I can show where that it
is. This
is very annoying to type like this.
It doesn't allow me, unfortunately, to share the
entire screen
full screen.
So I have to go here. But if
I go back to this Sveltos documentation,
there is a section which explains
how to register a cluster with Sveltos.
And there is, like, an example. Essentially, it
all Sveltos requires is to
get the KubeConfig
to create a service account in the managed
cluster,
which allows Sveltos to deploy add ons and
push, like, create resource on the cluster.
And the commendation is just here. And for
GKE, there is pretty much like this script
that I put in there, which does pretty
much everything it takes to keep config from
from the cluster. Does that work for GKE
and EKS where they need, like, that second
factor, you know, like, the g cloud?
Does it need to get the service account,
I guess?
So it will work for any cluster which
allows you to get the KubeConfig
and
allows you to use that KubeConfig process the
cluster without requiring,
you know,
any
third
tool
installed pretty much to to us. Sometimes, like,
if you use,
I think, some of the
I forgot what it may be. Like but
let's say that you are creating, like, a
cluster which one
of the cloud providers, and they require you
to install their own CLI. So even after
you download, like, the KubeConfig, the KubeConfig internally,
it's calling the
this cloud provider CLI to to work. I
mean, in that case, pretty much, Sveltos won't
work. So Sveltos will work every time you
have, like, a cube config that you can
pass to Sveltos. Sveltos can load that cube
config and automatically pretty much can assist the
cluster
without requiring any.
Okay. Cool.
So I'll go back
to
I apologize for this switching back and forth.
Don't worry about it. All good.
So
as I was saying, like, Sveltos has a
CLI. So what I'm doing here is, like
sorry. It's a that
I'm gonna run the register cluster.
So
what I'm doing, it's I don't ever like
to pass this anymore because, like, mycubecom
my cube catalog is pointing directly to the
management cluster, I can get rid of this.
And Sveltos Kaddle is the CLI that comes
with Sveltos.
Again, it's not required. It's it's it's useful
to I find it useful. I use it
all the time. Clearly, I'm biased because I
developed it.
But what I'm saying what I'm asking Sveltos
is to register a cluster
and
create the instance that represents this cluster in
the GKE namespace,
call it cluster one.
And the KubeConfig,
it's
it's the KubeConfig that I store, which is
the
just
yeah. It's called
GKE cluster one.
So this is pretty much like
the cube config that I took from DGKE
cluster.
So right now, I'm creating this one, and
I'm gonna do the same for the other
cluster as well. So I'll call it cluster
two because pretty much it's how I
call, like, on on.
It's just like for simplicity.
And now if I can say that so
there is, again, there is one cluster, which
is cluster API provider
power,
but there is also two
Sveltos clusters.
Sveltos cluster pretty much like are using the
cube conflict that they just passed, like, to
manage those two g k clusters.
Now I have prepared, like, a few
I did prepare, like, one
few configurations that I wanna show. So there
is one cluster profile,
which this is a very basic one. So
what I'm doing, like, I'm asking Sveltos
to deploy
in
any cluster matching like this
cluster selector here, environment function verification,
and also to deploy the content of this
content map.
And what I'm gonna put, like, in this
content map,
it's
it's a Caverno policy. So I think I
download like this. I do have the Caverno
policy here. Just a Cavernoplastic policy which
prevents
any
image with the latest start to be deployed.
So what I'm gonna do, like, I'm gonna
create a
config map
with the content of this file here. So
I'm creating a config map into the following
space and then call it, cabernaletas,
and the content is coming from the file
that we just saw.
So if I'm gonna look at this config
map here,
Because essentially the in the data section, it
has the cluster policy here.
Now before I go and pause the cluster
profile,
if I look at the I want to
add, like, the proper label for the clusters.
So
I can start doing the, like, an edit
of the
cluster API, power cluster.
And
it has few labels, but this is the
label I'm gonna use, like, in the cluster
profile, environment function verification. So I'm adding this
label here,
and I'm gonna do the same for the
Bell plus clusters that I have. So it's
Yeah. Still looking at your terminal just as
a reminder.
Yes. Can can you see me editing? Like,
just to make sure that I'm showing sharing
the right record No. I I don't see
editing. We're still looking at the get Sveltos
cluster dash here. Okay.
This is a bummer. Sorry.
Stop sharing.
And
even if I switch tab,
I think so,
essentially, what I did, I
I add
I downloaded like this
cluster policy.
Can you see now the cluster policy? Yes.
I see it. Yeah. Okay. And then what
I did, I created
config
map that contains this cluster policy here. This
is like in the data section, it contains
the config map
cluster
policy.
And then the other things that I did,
I went to the
cluster which is created by
powered by cluster API,
and I added this label here, environment functional
verification.
Because I added this label because I'm gonna
use this label in the cluster profile.
So so far, I only have, like, this
label here. There is nothing else done. And
now I'm also going to do the same
for the two
Sveltos clusters that I created. So Sveltos clusters
in the g k namespace.
I think I called one cluster one.
And I'm going to add the same label
to this cluster here.
So environment is function verification.
And I'm gonna do the same for the
third cluster.
So
environment function verification. So at this point, all
the clusters
have this level here.
Now I do have this cluster profile here,
which
I haven't posted yet, but, essentially, what this
cluster is saying, it's it's cluster profile saying
it it's instructing Sveltos to
take
find all the clusters which have this level
here, environment functional verification,
and to deploy and
chart,
and to also deploy the content of this
config map here, which we saw it's it's
just like a cluster policy.
So
as soon as I post this cluster here,
just gonna show something else.
There is no cluster profile yet.
So I'm going to and there is no
cluster summary yet. I'm gonna show what this
cluster summary is. But so
I'm going to apply
the cluster policy.
So cluster because I profile with the.
As soon as I apply
this cluster profile here, what Sveltos does,
it's it figures out automatically that there are
three clusters which are bot matching.
And it creates a cluster summary for
every per cluster profile matching cluster. So I
have three clusters that which are matching this
cluster profile.
And so it creates, like, three cluster summary.
This allows Sveltos pretty much to know per
cluster what to do.
So if I go and I can use,
like, this Sveltos CLI at this point to
show the add ons. So I'm simply like
there's this Sveltos CLI.
It has a
bunch of commands.
I'm gonna show you, like, some of the
commands.
And one of the commands is add on.
And if I ask to
show me what the add ons are, it's
gonna display all the add ons that that
Sveltos have deployed so far.
So when I look at it,
you know, it's like I can see that
so far, he has deployed Caverno
version and chart version three zero one at
this time here in the
cluster API power cluster.
And it has deployed a cluster policy, a
Caverno cluster policy
with this name here
at this time, again, in this cluster here
because of this cluster profile here, Caverno.
Now I think it's still deploying in the
other two GKE cluster. It takes a little
longer for add ons to be deployed there.
It's like but
this is, like, now
it has deployed its
Caverno
and chart in the cluster one. In the
cluster two, pretty much, it's done deploying everything.
And the cluster one is still missing the
cluster pull up policy, which hopefully by now
is deployed. So, yes, now at this point,
pretty much, everything is there. And I can
see the exact time when it was deployed
in each one of those clusters.
Are these add ons just CRDs? Like, can
you just run cube control get Sveltos add
ons as Sveltos add ons?
Is that how this work?
So
no. That's pretty much like it's this Sveltos
card or show add ons. It's it's pretty
much just showing you what resources,
what add ons Sveltos has deployed in each
cluster so far.
Okay. So I can actually Could I get
that myself with kubectl? That's what I was
Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. Absolutely. Yes. For instance,
like, if we look let's go to to
one of the cluster here. So I have
we can take, like, the cluster API of
our cluster.
Right? So if I do this
and I do, like, a QCalow get
pods, for instance, you can see that the
has been deployed.
You see?
Yes. And you can see that the
cluster policy, it's also been deployed. Like, it
it's a it's at the Sveltos Kabo, pretty
much like it's a it's it it runs
in the management cluster and so it's a
centralized place where you can go into, like,
show me, like,
call the I don't so you don't have,
like, to keep changing your Qt config, like,
to switch from one of the managed cluster
to the other. Hey. Can you run That's
to control API resources and correct it for
Sveltos so I could see what what custom
resources that deploys to the management cluster?
You can
show
oh, in the management cluster.
Yeah.
Yes. So pretty much like the resources that
Sveltos is deploying so far are, like, it's
it's I know. But I can you show
me the output of API dash resources
For Sveltos?
Yeah.
Okay. Yes.
I just I'm very curious. That's all. No.
Absolutely. Yes. Yes. Yes. Sorry. Don't understand your
your question. So those are the
all the different CRDs that Sveltos has. So
so far, the only ones that we are
using, it's the cluster profile and the cluster
summary.
And
this is something
that we can configure.
This is something that is not supposed to
be configured like Sveltos
configures in it on on its own to
keep track pretty much of the progress on
every managed clusters.
And then the cluster configuration,
it's if you wanna see pretty much without
using Sveltos
without using this Sveltos CLI, you can actually
look at this cluster configuration here, and there
should be one resources per cluster.
And for instance, if we look at this
one,
it
this contains
all the add ons that Sveltos has deployed
and why. And this is pretty much what
the Sveltos catalog does. It goes and beats
this config this cluster configuration here,
and it knows how to parse, like, this
information here and display, like, in a human
little pivot table. Okay. Yeah. That's what I
was use, like
yeah. You don't have to use this Sveltos
Kaddle. Pretty much, you can use like, you
can go and look at the cluster configuration,
and it gives you exactly the same information
that this Sveltos Kaddle does. Except that pretty
much in this case, you will have to
read the three of these because pretty much
there are three different class that are managed
by Sveltos.
But yeah.
Absolutely. You don't have to use as as
I mentioned, like, Sveltos Gaddle is fully optional.
It's not it's not needed.
There's
a question from the audience, which I'm gonna
drop in just now where we're we're chatting.
So Harsh is asking,
I'm trying to picture the get up story.
Is it going to be Argo or Flux
to manage the management cluster
and let Sveltos manage apps?
Is there like, how do you see Sveltos
in a landscape of It's actually this is
a very good questions.
Thank you for the question. I the way
I see it is that
I would use flux
to push the configuration to the management cluster.
And once it reaches the management cluster, I
will use Sveltos to send it to the
managed clusters. The reason pretty much I will
do that way is because the configuration that
you push to the management cluster, you clearly
pretty much wanna have, like, all the advantage
of the detox approach, right, where you can
do a review of any
change. You can have a history of every
change.
It's you can have your CICD pipeline before
pretty much it reaches the management cluster. But
once it reaches the management cluster, I think
the the the
benefit of using Sveltos is that Sveltos is
capable of
fetching information from the management cluster and use
this information here
to
customize
or configure the advance that are then going
to be deployed to every managed clusters. And
for instance, like, if a new cluster is
added that is managed by Sveltos,
you know, there is no configuration that needs
to change the management cluster. Let's say that
I create another
cluster API per work cluster using Docker as
infrastructure provider. As soon as I add the
label environment functional verification, it means that this
cluster should have and this cluster policy deployed,
and Sveltos will take care from there. So
there is nothing else that I have to
do. So
I do see to to
answer again the question, like, I do see
flux
as the tool
to push the configuration to the management cluster.
And once he reaches the management cluster, I
see Sveltos as
the solution to to deploy. The other reason
I would use Sveltos in that case because
Sveltos has features like, for instance, you may
say,
if in any of the cluster, you see
that there is this event here, for instance,
a service is created,
this is the set of add ons that
they want to deploy in response of that
service being created. So with Sveltos, you can
do that. So it's more dynamic. Right? You
can react to,
cluster on time stage changes. You can react,
like, to events in any of the managed
cluster, which is difficult, like, to express
in in a GitOps approach. But the configuration
cost to manage my cluster should should should
come with plugs
if I were to do it. Actually, this
is how pretty much, like, I internally do
it.
Okay. Thank you.
There is since we are, in scale, there's
one something else that I wanna show. For
instance, let's say that now I I wanna
make a change. Right?
But
I'm not sure about what the outcome is.
So I want, for instance, to change the
caverno
from
and chart from three zero one to three
zero two. But I don't know what the
outcome is going to be. Right?
What I can tell Sveltos is, please go
in dry run mode.
Right? In dry run mode, what Sveltos is
going to do, it's not gonna make any
change to the managed clusters.
But it's internally gonna run like the full
logic that it will run. So pretty much,
like, it will run all the steps that
it will execute
when it deploys a once. It's just like
it will skip the last one, which is
actually the real deployment to the managed cluster.
So if I change this cluster profile and
I say it's like, I
wanna upgrade but
be in dry end mode because I don't
know what the outcome is going to be.
Now I can use again
Sveltoscalo,
and I forgot what the command is in
that case.
I think it's a dry run. Yes. Okay.
So it's I can tell Sveltos, show me
what will change if I were to commit
this change. And if you see what it's
gonna say is that it's gonna say that
the Caverno in it's gonna be the current
version 30.1,
and we'll move to version 30.2
in this cluster here. And same pretty much
like, you know, the cluster. Right? So there
would be like a Caverno
and Sharp upgrade.
But with respect to the cluster policy,
there's no change. The object is already deployed,
and there is no change. You you haven't
changed the configuration affecting this object, so there
is no change there. So pretty much, you
can review, like, what the you can make
a change. You can review the change. And
if you find the change, you can go
back and tell Sveltos, okay. Now deploy it.
Or if you're not fine with the change,
just revert back to whatever you were.
So this is something pretty much like that,
especially when managing, like, a fleet of clusters.
It's
it's tough to
and you wanna make sure that only a
certain
you you wanna make sure what the side
effect is going to be. Like, it's it's
nice to have, like, this dry run command.
See, the
sorry. Just related to that. Right? Let's assume
we wanted to change from
dry run. There's also continuous.
I've got two clusters about to be upgraded.
Say one of them is considered lower risk
by the organization. Can we tell Sveltos to
apply it to that one first? And if
it's successful, continue the rule, like, you know,
like a phased rollout of a deployment across
the add on.
That's a
not right now. So the way you will
have to do right now is to
have different labels in that cluster there. So,
for instance, like, the way I will solve
it, I will,
I will call that cluster there, for instance,
preproduction
and the other cluster production, let's say. Yeah.
And then I will have, like, two cluster
profiles which are exactly then
one matching the preproduction and one matching the
production.
And then if you wanna actually
see the change live in the preproduction, you
just make the change to the cluster profile
there. You see what happens to the preproduction
cluster, and then you go back to the
to the other cluster profile and change it
there. But it's actually this is, like, it's
one of the
features that I would like to add. Well,
you also tell Sveltos,
which is the order.
If you make a change, I wanted you
to go and you are matching, like, 10
different clusters. I want you to go in
order. So go first to this cluster, then
to this cluster, then to this cluster, then
to this cluster. Yeah. But it's it's not
there yet, but it's it's a very good
point because it's it's something that definitely too
much you wanna see.
Cool. Thank you.
Now the other things I wanna show, it's
the the two so the cluster that I
have, it's running
one twenty six version. This is the cluster
profile.
While the two,
the two GK clusters
I don't know if I have this information
here, but they are running
do not have this information here, but they're
running one twenty seven. So they're running at
the different, like,
Kubernetes cluster.
So Kubernetes version. So what I created here,
like, I have one classifier.
And this classifier is saying that if you
find a cluster which is
greater or equal than one twenty six or
less than one twenty seven, I want this
cluster to have this label here, version b
one twenty six.
And then I'm gonna pair actually no. Actually,
here, I'm gonna pair this one with
cluster profile for one twenty six. So this
cluster profile here is saying, like, if you
see any cluster with one twenty six,
please deploy NGINX
ingress
version
18.
So I'm gonna pause both of those.
So I'm gonna pause first this one. All
these posts are going to the management cluster.
I'm gonna pause this, and I'm gonna pause
the
cluster profile
What's the name? For b one twenty six.
As soon as I post those two things,
now what you should happen if I go
in again and look at the add ons,
only one cluster, it's running one twenty six.
So I expect the NGINX is gonna deploy
only to one cluster. The other two clusters
should not have, like, this configuration deployed.
So so far, pretty much nothing is deployed
yet.
You know, I just deployed the
classifier, so the classifier is gonna get
pushed to the
manage clusters,
and then it's gonna come back
saying whether the cluster is a match or
not. At this point, I see that pretty
much, like, this information came back to the
management cluster,
and it should say that the cluster is
too much.
Let's take classify your reports.
Yeah. So this is back. So now if
I go and look at the on support
deployed,
you see that NGINX now has been deployed
only
to this cluster here. NGINX is not gonna
be deployed to the other cluster one and
cluster two because those two clusters are running
Kubernetes version, which is 01/1972.
So the only cluster which is running a
Kubernetes version, which is
greater or lower than one twenty six and
less than one twenty seven is this cluster
here. And
so this is the only cluster which is
matching this
classifier.
And because this is the only cluster that
is matching the classifier here, which is running
a version between one twenty six and less
than one twenty seven, this is the only
cluster where
NGINX is gonna be deployed.
And
and we saw it looking at the advance
that, again, like, it's just like nothing else
is deployed. This is the only place where
NGINX has been deployed.
And
if I look at the cluster
so I get to my edit.
Just to, like, get cluster.
If we look at this cluster here, we
can see that Sveltos
added this label here, version one twenty six.
But if we look at the
Sveltos cluster, the other two Sveltos cluster,
cluster one, for instance,
the GK namespace.
No. The label has not been added because
it's pretty much like this cluster is not
a match.
So this is the
classifier demo that you can say
what advance you want to be deployed based
on the cluster run time state.
Nice. I wanna post here, like, if there
is any question. Otherwise, pretty much, like, I
have another
features that I would like to demo,
which is the event driven framework.
But I will post here, like, if there's
any question.
Okay. I mean, what can we do with
the the classifiers?
Could you run a cube control explain on
the spec so we can see what the
what that looks like.
Yes.
So
just
see here.
See what's the
filters, and this is the
classifier.
Okay. So it's this classifier here so I
can get the
Alright. Is there any other command which is
better Yeah. You can run cube control, explain,
and then space,
c r d name dot spec.
I'm
like this? Yeah.
Perfect. Oh, alright. That's Yeah. You could do
that with any nested field that expands. It's
really cool and my favorite command. Oh, that's
perfect.
That's great. Yeah. Pretty much like what
the classifier
you to do. It's we saw pretty much
classifying a cluster based on the Kubernetes version,
but it can also classify a cluster based
on the
the
deployed resources.
So for instance, now
so if I if
I take this one, it's gonna go farther
into that. Right? Yeah. Correct.
K. So you see pretty much, like, you
can tell Sveltos classify
a cluster based on
take this group, this kind,
take this label filters to filter object, like,
of this group kind
version.
You can say it's like if there is
a max count or a min count of
resources,
and you can even pass, like, a Lua
script.
Okay. So you so you can pretty much,
like, cusses, like, any field in any of
those resources.
And then you can say pretty much whether
the
you know, like, if this return is true,
it means that the cluster is unmatched. So
you can
really look like at
at any deployed
can look at the cluster and decide the
the classified cluster based on the resources that
are deployed there. So it's it's Yeah. So,
like, using our example from earlier, if I've
got let's just say a WordPress website. Right?
And I don't want to deploy to the
cluster until there's a config map that exists
with everything I need, like DNS name and
TLS or whatever.
I would add a classifier that monitors for
that config map and then when it exists,
I deploy my application.
And I think this loops right into a
second question from Harsh.
He says, is there a way we could
order the app or resource installations?
For example,
make sure we install project x first because
why I need CRDs,
etcetera or webhooks
and a voice back off. I guess you
would use the classifiers and the resources to
do that too. Right? Maybe? Yes. Potentially, you
can do with the classifier exactly. Pretty much
you can say pretty much that
when you see that this CRD installed,
then at this label, which it's causing the
cluster to be a match for a cluster
profile, which contains your second set of accounts
that you want to be deployed, and then
you can keep, like, piping into that
so you can have, like, a multistage deployment.
The other things is, like, if you have
if all your resources are,
let's say, in charts or customization file or
resources, like, instance. If you put if you
have two
hand charts that you want to deploy and
there is
Sveltos is gonna honor the order that you
put here. It's gonna first deploy Caverno. And
if here, like, I have, like, a second
after Caverno, here, I have, like, a second
hand chart. So the order in which Sveltos
is gonna be the it's gonna deploy the
resources that they first deployed Caverno,
then it passed to the second one, and
then it passed to the third one, and
so on. And same to successfully
deploy before moving through the list? Yes. Yes.
They will successfully deploy. Otherwise,
pretty much like if if you're three, like,
it's it will pretty much
first we have to successfully deploy before the
third one, like, it's it's installed. Otherwise, we'll
just before
customization
refs?
Oh, no. Essentially
no. So, essentially, the order is within any
section. So Right. End charts because pretty much
the way Sveltos does it, it's that
to
be fast,
what it does, like, it's it it
it takes, like, the end charts and deploys
the end charts. Sorry. And then in parallel,
it takes, like, those objects here and tries
to deploy this object here. And then it
takes something else and, you know, the customization
file and tries to deploy the customization file,
like, in parallel. So those things do a
customization for all of my CRDs,
that would have to be labels because
Yes. And then everything else that would be
ordered within helm and customized within the cluster
profile.
Okay. Got it. Yes. Absolutely. Yes.
Yeah. Or you pretty much will use the
classifier, like, to to put the order there.
Yeah.
Got it. Nice.
Yeah. I think I would have a cluster
profile for CRDs,
deploy
them. I have a classifier that one or
us for the CRDs and then applies the
labels that I need for my applications. I
think that's a pretty nice workflow.
Yes.
Thanks.
Okay. You said there was one more thing
you wanted to demo? Although we've got a
comment from Harsh just saying that's super cool.
So there we go. Oh, thank you. Thanks.
Thanks. Thank you.
Glad to hear that. Thanks.
Yeah. The if there are, like, more minutes,
I wanna show, like, the event
driven framework. So
as I mentioned, pretty much, like, Sveltos has
the ability to also deploy add ons in
response to events. So for instance here, like,
I'm gonna go, like, super fast on this
computer. Like I said, there are, like, only
few minutes left. But, essentially, there is a
concept of event source. So in this case,
what I'm saying is, like, it's
it's if there is service
with this label here, Sveltos functional verification,
this event, this is an event. Right? And
now I have the second CRB which says,
like,
look for this event here. This is like
this is referencing this event here. So it's
saying, like, look for this event in all
the cluster which have this level here.
And if
you see this event happening in any of
those clusters, I want you to deploy the
content of this config map here. And the
content of the config map is a network
policy, right, which is
using some information coming from, you know, the
service,
which is
matching event.
So I will deploy
this going to the managed cluster.
I'm deploying this into the managed cluster.
Now if, again, if I look at the
add ons,
nothing is changing because so far, too much,
I have, like, no such service deployed anywhere.
But now I do have
okay. Yes. I do have a a service
example. You know, it's
very stupid example, but the important part is
that this is a service which is has
the right label, so it's matching the event
that I defined.
So for instance, I can deploy this one
to the oh, no. Cluster two. I'll just
deploy it to cluster two.
Once
again, nothing is there yet. It's like there's
nothing. So now I'm going to deploy this
one to cluster two. So to config.
Git config.
Git
git
Config. K. I'm gonna go let you keep
a dollar tie of this example service. So
I'm deploying this example service into the
config.
cluster two.
And now I what I expect is that
Sveltos should detect that this event has up
and, like, just in this cluster here and
should deploy, a network policy in this cluster.
So just gonna give it
sometimes to
So how is the case a little low.
Event add on different from a deployed resource
classifier?
Like, how what's how do you know when
to use either one?
It's
it's it's
I would say, like, it's
the the only difference, it's whether
you want to
I would say that you use the classifier
when you want Sveltos to manage the labels
for you.
And you use this event mechanism when you
don't want Sveltos to touch the cluster labels,
but you want Sveltos to see deploy your
own in response to events.
So because for instance, if you look here,
right,
at the
event based alone. Right? I'm not telling Sveltos
to add any labels. I'm saying, like, look
at all the cluster which add this label
here,
environment functional verification.
And if you see these events, then deploy
those around here. So the difference is
purely whether you want Sveltos to manage the
cluster labels for you or you simply want
Sveltos to react to events.
That is pretty much what will say the
only difference. The outcome is the same. Adults
are deployed in response to
cluster runtime state changing.
Okay. Got it.
So if we look here, yes. Now we
see that pretty much there is a network
policy which has been installed just like in
this cluster here and nowhere else.
Because, you know, Sveltos detected that there is
the this event has happened, like, in this
cluster, and so it's gonna deploy the onset
we told Sveltos to to deploy in the
cluster.
What happens if you delete the surface?
It should delete this add on here. So
we can do that.
So we can
apply it and then delete.
No pressure. But the service
the service has been deleted,
and, hopefully,
we should see that, yes, my Sveltos detected,
but it's not too much anymore, and so
I removed, like, the network policy from the
cluster.
Yeah. So behind the scenes, that event add
on detected the service, and it looks like
it created a class a dynamic cluster profile.
Is that right? Yes. Yes. Absolutely. Yes. You're
right. When pretty much like
it created, like, a cluster profile with the
list of add ons that you listed in
the event based add on, and then you
deploy those ones here.
Because you already know pretty much, like, in
the the the cluster work to deploy.
But it did deploy just in that cluster.
So it cleared, like, a cluster profile just
for that cluster there.
Very cool. I like that.
Thanks.
Yeah. That was
it for the demo. I'll
stop sharing so I can
see your face again.
Okay.
Harsh asked the final question and was just
curious
if we have multiple cluster profiles to those
run-in parallel
if the labels exist. They do run-in they
do run-in parallel, but Sveltos is an internal
mechanism because if you have multiple cluster profile,
If you have no misconfiguration, that's fine. They
will done in parallel. They will deploy all
things in parallel. All good.
If there is a misconfiguration,
for instance,
you have a cluster profile that says, like,
deploy
Elm Caverno,
Elm version
three point zero point one in this cluster,
in this namespace.
And you have another cluster profile that says
in the same namespace, in the same cluster
deploy Caverno version
2.7.
Clearly, that is a misconfiguration, right, because you
can have only one, right, in the very
same namespace. And so what Sveltos does is
the text that that is a misconfiguration.
So the first cluster profile
can go and deploy the cavernium charts. And
on the second cluster profile, you will have,
like,
an error message saying,
these other cluster profiles managing
this cavernal chart. So you
wanna make sure. So it's actually pointing you
to where the misconfiguration is, where the conflict
is. So it gives you the right information
so you can easily fix the configuration.
Cool. But they do run-in parallel.
Nice. Yeah. It's it's a really nice project.
So thank you for coming on and sharing
it. I've kinda
mentally went through a bit of a journey.
At the start, I thought,
you know, this is and they get up
space. It competes with flux and Argo, but
I've kind of finished thinking that's not where
it is at all. It's a completely different
layer.
I actually see a world where I could
have Sveltos doing the classifiers,
labeling clusters and then as part of the
cluster profiles deploying,
you know,
flux resources or Argo CD resources to other
clusters as well and doing a handoff to
a certain way. And I think the really
neat thing about Sveltos is that dynamic nature,
the classifiers, the event based add ons, even
the ability to inject a little bit of
Lua. I love that as well. Like, I'm
a huge Lua fan. So, like, all these
things working together That's great. Yeah. Just give
you this really nice
little dynamic run time on top of the
fleet or Kubernetes clusters.
Something I haven't seen like, I don't know
if you remember the the gate project
from like five, six years ago.
It came out of Microsoft and it was
like a event based run time JavaScript framework
to handle and react to events within the
Kubernetes cluster. And Sveltos is bringing the best
bits of that back out in a really
neat way. So yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
No. Thanks. Yeah. I mean, I like as
I mentioned, like, I've been working, like, on
distributed systems. So when I start with Sveltos,
the idea was
I've seen, like, the set of problems, like,
in a different context, you know, like, a
a data center.
But but some of those problems here, like,
can be easily
applied to Kubernetes fleet of clusters if I
say that the controller that sends the controller
is the management cluster and the all these
switches are the separate, like, Kubernetes clusters here.
So, like, some of those problems here pretty
much can be brought into this context from
different context and then soft here. So
and it has, like, other features, like, also,
like, supports, like, multitenancy because sometimes, you know,
if you have a fleet of but in
these clusters,
sometimes you might wanna say it's like, you
can manage all the clusters which are with
these labels, and I can manage, a different
set of clusters. And so at that point,
there, pretty much it has a way to
say is, like, if I'm configuring something, it
verifies that I'm allowed to deploy those accounts
in those clusters, whether, like, US platform admin
has given me as a parent admin permission
to do those things or not. So Sveltos
like supports it as well.
Cool. I think we have two more questions,
one from Harsh and one from me. So
I'll throw Harsh's up first. How lightweight can
the management cluster be? Would it work on
any distribution?
Connect a bunch of operators to it without
worker nodes. So, like, can they run this
on just a single node control plane setup?
So let me see how many, like, nodes
I do work here. In the management cluster,
in this demo
here, I was doing, like, three clusters, and
I had only one
worker node and one control plane nodes, which
is running on a kind local. So, like,
it's even, like, limited the amount of CPU
and memory that you can take because otherwise,
was like nothing else would work on my
laptop. So
it should
honestly, like, again, I haven't
tested this scale with
more than tens of clusters.
So I don't know if you go, like,
into the hundreds what the problem would be.
Ideally, the design internal is done in a
way that eliminates the amount of operations that
it does in parallel, so it doesn't require,
like, too much operation. For instance, you can
configure, like
it has this concept of
a long queue job. Deploying an advance is
a long queue job. Right? So you can
tell Sveltos the maximum number of long queue
operation that you can have in parallel. So
if you have, like, 100 clusters that you're
managing and you're managing, like, one of configuration,
pretty much like if you say it's, like,
10 long queue operations can go in parallel,
that's what Sveltos gonna do. Like, it's gonna
run 10, and as soon as one is
done, it was gonna take the next one
and do it.
So
it potentially has the way, like, of scaling
well because
but even Tesla, like if someone is is,
like,
hundreds of clusters and want to try, like,
a gladly get any bug and fix it
and improve it. But I don't have, like,
that many clusters to to try. Alright. Awesome.
I hope that answers your question, Harsh.
So let's finish up with why don't you
tell us what's coming next for the the
project? And if you wanna share, where did
the name come from?
The name come from because
I was
discussing with another guy, which is
and he mentioned pretty much, like, he loves
boats, and
he told me that Sveltos
in ancient Greek
means
a fleet,
and that's pretty much, like, why I took,
like, the project Sveltos. It's like, oh, yeah.
Managing, a fleet of clusters. It means, like,
fleet at least
unless someone I I trusted this guy, so
I hope that I'm not
it's the right information or not.
With respect to the set of features,
I do have, like,
list I can tell you, like, the one
that I'm currently working on. Essentially, I want
Sveltos to also
take care of
let's say that you are deploying a deployment
or a stateful site with Sveltos,
and it's
mounting a config map or a secret, which
is also might also be deployed or not
by Sveltos. What I want you what I
want Sveltos to do is to detect when
the config map, it's changed
and
reload
the trigger a rolling upgrade of the deployment.
This is actually a feedback that I got,
like, from the team.
So,
you know, it's a thank to them,
Dario and team.
And it made a lot of sense, so
that's the one I'm working on pretty much.
Like, so you don't have to worry about
if you have a a certificate in a
config map and a deployment which is mounting
that certificate
and you rotate that certificate. So
Sveltos will be able to automatically
trigger a rolling update upgrade of your deployment
as soon as this the text that the
config map is upgraded in the managed cluster.
So you don't have to worry about that
as well. Because I I think, like, all
those problems here are every time we have
to ask the admin to
do something in response to another event, it's
when it becomes a real problem because, like,
at least
I have, like, a
short span attention, and I
I will pretty much, like, mess it up,
like, unless there is
Sveltos or something else behind the scene that
takes care of
Okay. That for me. Alright. We had a
question sneaking at the end there that'll throw
up in the screen. And I'm really sorry.
I don't wanna try and pronounce that name
because I'll I'll make a mess of it.
But the question is, can a cluster profile
use more than one helm chart and how
does Sveltos behave in the case that it
fails to deploy one? Does it roll back
all the changes? We kinda covered this a
little bit, but maybe you could go into
it in a bit more detail.
So, yeah, I see, like, his name is
Julio. Julio. He can yeah.
He can deploy
he can reference more than one end chart.
And
the order,
it's sequential. So if you have, like, three
end charts, we'll deploy the first. And only
if the first is successfully deployed, it will
deploy the second. And only if the second
is successfully deployed, it will go on the
third one. Let's say that I deployed the
first one and the second one failed.
No. It's gonna it's not going to roll
back. It it will keep
retrying,
trying to deploy the second one. So it
will deport what the error is. So if
any error pretty much that he sees, like,
it will deport back in the cluster summary
so you know exactly what it is spelling,
but it won't roll back. So it will
be, like, up to the customers. It's like,
okay. First
one
succeeded. Second, didn't succeed. So I'll just delete
the cluster profile, which will be drawn on
the deployed ones.
Because the idea is that it's they keep
retrying stuff. You know? The error may be
temporary, and
it will report the error on them. If
we can move forward, we move forward. Yeah.
It's Kubernetes. Everything's eventually consistent. So Yes. Absolutely.
Alright. Well, thank you for taking time out
of your day to to join us, preparing
that demo, going over the slides, all of
that was was fantastic. It was great to
see the project. I definitely have some use
cases that I'm gonna have to kick the
tires on it and play with. So, yeah.
Thank you for your time today. Thank
you. Thank you for having me here. Thanks.
Alright. Thank you everyone for watching. We'll see
you all next time. Have a great week
and a good weekend.
Adios.